herzlich Willkommen zu Folge 2 wenn man
so will von dem Format in dem nicht ich
koche sondern ein anderer Max und ich
irgendeiner sondern Maximilian Lorenz
ihr habt es gesehen es hat Euch sehr gut
gefallen mir genauso gut deshalb sind
wir heute wieder da wir kochen nicht mit
10 Euro pro Person sondern mit 20 und
das ändert alles also wir haben wirklich
einen großen großen Verfügungsrahmen
wenn man so will ja mit Max Lorenz als
unserem Sternekoch an der Seite gucken
wir jetzt mal was man damit leckeres
zaubern kann du hast die Regie wenn es
ums Kochen geht los also ähm letzte Mal
schon mit 10 € finde ich hat mega Spaß
gemacht und hast du gesagt komm wir
setzen einen drauf ja und auf einmal
wieder so das Herz auf was man Ware
kaufen kann ja ich sag ganz kurz was wir
machen wir machen einmal ein bisschen
Cris mit einem Avocado Tartan mit Gurke
und grüner Paprika da machen wir ein
klassisches Haar im Hauptgang machen wie
eine rinderfilette mit ein bisschen
Ofengemüse und für mich der geilste Soße
und auch für Eric Bernies selbstgemacht
und zum Dessert versuche ich oder wir
versuchen uns im Thema Backen ja wir
machen nämlich einen Karotten
Mandelkuchen mit einer kleinen Creme und
ein selbstgemachte
natürlich auch jederzeit mit so in der
warmen Zeit gebrauchen kann wir werden
es probieren genau und das klingt alles
normal so wie man sich vorstellen kann
aber ich habe allein bei der Besprechung
des Menüs schon so viele Tricks und
Tipps entdeckt auch mit dem Hobby also
lohnt sich auf jeden Fall dran zu
bleiben gib mir meine erste Aufgabe und
ich werde genau du fängst an mit dem
Karottenkuchen du fehlst die Karotten
und dann quasi auf der groben Seite der
Reibe runterlaufen lassen die Butter
haben wir hier schon ein bisschen
aufgeschlagen die werden wir quasi
nachher in die Schüssel mit reinreiben
warum schlägt man Butter auf was hat das
schon sinnlos Weg dadurch dass du die
Butter aufschlägst schlägst du Luft
unter und quasi die Mutter
verfilzseitigt sich von dem Volumen und
du kannst Sachen einarbeiten zum
Beispiel so ein Klassiker ist jetzt
gleich kommt ein bisschen Mehl mit dazu
es ist sehr nachher aus wie so eine
gewonnene Kräuterbutter okay ja das
wollen wir nicht da habe ich gesagt habe
schon Rinder haben und in die Vollen
greifen machen wir oben drauf eine Senf
Kruste wow das ist ein Affinität für
französische Wörter also wir haben hier
ein bisschen aufgeschlagene Butter drin
dann den Senf gehen wir mit beiden ein
bisschen ähm
ich glaube nachher geht es auch einfach
darum wir haben das Glück dass wir uns
gesucht und gefunden haben und eine
schöne Zeit miteinander verbringen aber
es geht ja auch beim Kochen um Spaß
haben und dann kocht man einfach
zusammen ich habe fertig geschrieben
jetzt super du kannst es jetzt mal in
deine Küchenmaschine geben und das ist
eigentlich relativ chillig dieses Rezept
weil du einfach alle Zutaten zusammentun
kannst dann bräuchten wir noch ein
bisschen Zucker und ein bisschen Mehl
und das ist hier für mich ich weiß nicht
kennst du Bittermandelaroma
das alter Schwede das riecht einfach so
wie Amaretto ja ja ja machen jetzt mal
so sechs sieben Tropfen rein das reicht
vollkommen aus bist du denn ein süßer ja
musst du sagen wie gesagt
Zucker rein fertig können ja noch ein
bisschen Zitrone Abrieb reinmachen du
hast deine Reibe hier ja und Zitrone
haben wir sowieso später
dann können wir quasi sagen vom Notes
Hotel bei der Pflanzen einfach ein
bisschen Abrieb rein so wie du magst
nicht dein Leben
alles klar
sehen wir alles zusammen kommt
eigentlich wirklich überschaubare
Zutaten einfach verrühren und dann haben
wir unseren Rührkuchen so sieht das
Ganze aus und ich wünschte es gibt
Youtube das riecht so stark nach Mandel
nach Karotte einfach so süß frisch und
oft macht mir irgendwie Kirschkuchen
Apfelkuchen etc was kaum einer weiße
Karotte enthält so viel Zucker dass man
das getroffen
einfach viel mehr Karotten und auch
meine Nüsse weg lässt die ist das
nachher echt ein Zucker Bombe ich weiß
nicht wie es euch geht aber für mich
persönlich und ein Getränk ein perfekt
ab und viele der Dinge die man trinken
kann die lecker sind sind leider nicht
wirklich gut für uns eigentlich ist vor
allem Wasser gut für uns denn das jetzt
nur noch nach etwas schmecken würde aber
dafür gibt es jetzt eine Lösung ja ab
ist die neue Art zu trinken und Erb soll
nichts ersetzen er ab soll kein Bier
sein soll keine Cola sein kann nicht er
ab ist einfach Wasser mit mehr Geschmack
und euch somit wieder Spaß geben oder
noch mehr Spaß daran geben Wasser zu
trinken aber wie funktioniert er
eigentlich auf die eigens konzipierte er
abflasche setzt ihr euren duftpott den
könnt ihr frei auswählen und füllt
Wasser hinein die Ports gibt's in vielen
verschiedenen Geschmacksrichtungen
Eistee Pfirsich Holunder und speziell
zum Valentinstag Erdbeer Balsamico
klingt ein bisschen verrückt oder aber
die Kombination ist ja bekanntlich gut
sobald ihr den Duft dann hochzieht
aktiviert er sich und ihr könnt trinken
dadurch dass man an der Flasche trinkt
entsteht ein Sog welcher nicht nur
Wasser aus der Trinkflasche zieht
sondern auch Luft diese Luft wird quasi
durch den Pott in eure Nase gezogen und
sagt eurem Gehirn hey Geschmack und ich
hätte wirklich nicht gedacht dass es so
gut funktioniert also man schmeckt
wirklich etwas man denkt nicht oder
riecht etwas sondern man schmeckt
wirklich im Mund irgendwie keine Ahnung
das ganze nennt man übrigens Retro
nasales riechen auf dieser Art und Weise
hast du deine Wahrnehmung an der Nase
herumgeführt und ich persönlich kann nur
sagen ich trinke seitdem ich eher
benutze viel mehr Wasser weil es ist
irgendwie so keine Pflicht sondern es
macht Spaß hier noch die Flasche
wunderschön Special Edition macht sich
super hier in der Küche und wenn ihr
Lust auf mehr habt dann checkt er ab
guckt einfach in der Beschreibung vorbei
alles für euch verlinkt vielen lieben
Dank fürs unterstützende Videos jetzt
geht es weiter mit einem köstlichen
Gericht wenn ihr keine Ofenform habt
könnt ihr auch einfach eine Pfanne
nehmen oder einen kleinen Topf ich habe
keine Ahnung das kommt jetzt bei 160
180 Minuten einfach in den Backofen
kommen wir nun zur nächsten Step an
dieser Trikots haben wir fertig ich
würde jetzt gerne die beiden Tartare
machen von Lachs und Greens hatte was Du
machen könntest Max wäre das Ofengemüse
schneiden tobt dich aus bei dem was wir
haben und einfach nachher wieder ein
bisschen mit Olivenöl Rosmarin Thymian
marinieren so das vegetar haben wir
quasi fertig und jetzt mal ein bisschen
das lachstatter ich habe das Regal
gerade schon probiert crazy den Lachs
sind jetzt einfach kurz von der Haut ist
halt leider mal ein bisschen Verlust
dabei wenn wir den Lachs roh essen finde
ich nicht so lecker diesen Kran mit dran
zu haben wir entfernen wir einfach
schnell ich habe jetzt den Lachs
gewürfelt der Lachs wird ja quasi zum
Tatar Auswürfen wenn man ihn ein
bisschen feiner durch hat machen ein
bisschen Zitronensaft dran ein bisschen
Koriander ein bisschen Schmand ich nehme
auch noch einfach um das zu emulgieren
und was man halt auch machen kann wenn
man jetzt keinen frischen Lachs bekommt
also ich glaube in jedem Supermarkt
Discounter geräucherten Lachs ja gerade
für diejenigen die vielleicht irgendwie
Bedenken haben das Rot zu essen mit
geräuchteten seid ihr auf der sicheren
Seite ich mache hier drüben einfach das
grob geschnittene Grillgemüse verteidig
auf dem Blech irgendwie das schöne beim
Ofengemüse Taste keine zu aber du hast
noch drei Karotten übrig du kannst ja
quasi alles drauf tun und vor allem wenn
die Kartoffeln nachher knusprig werden
dann denkst du noch so ein bisschen so
er hat so ein bisschen Pommes Charakter
und jetzt stell dir das einfach mal vor
mit dem saftigen Rinderfilet oben drauf
die Kruste die so hinschmelzen ist und
dazu diese wohlwollende aufgeschlagene
so spennés zu krass das Ding wirklich zu
krass und ich habe sehr große Lust
darauf so noch ein bisschen Knoblauch
ein bisschen Zitronensaft rein und nicht
wirklich viel ein bisschen Olivenöl ganz
leicht nur dann haben wir dann die
mediterone auch noch drin das das fängt
auch direkt an durch das Öl noch so ein
bisschen zu glänzen ne schon fast so
leicht goldig schöne Farben irgendwie
hart das ist hart die Zeit vergeht wie
im Flug habe ich das Gefühl ganz kurz
was haben wir gemacht wir haben einen
Kuchen ein Großteil unseres Desserts
tätig Grillgemüse Großteil der
Hauptspeise fertig
Vorspeise fertig das heißt mit großen
Schritten lernen wir uns jetzt dem Ziel
ich Form jetzt so crispy Reis Quadrate
gerade die an von beiden Seiten
goldbraun ich mache noch eine schnelle
Creme zum Dessert die Leute kennen ja
irgendwie so du musst so Schokolade so
eine himbeermus und das sind alles viel
zu kompliziert wir haben mehr quasi ein
Becher Schmand gekauft und davon braucht
er nicht alles und da gibt es dann immer
eine ganz ganz tolle Sache einfach
Schmand ein bisschen Honig
Agavendicksaft
ein bisschen Zimt rein für immer
was ist das schon wieder wir haben hier
ein bisschen Sushi Reis davon nehme ich
einfach immer so klein wenig steckt das
in Setzling Form das aus damit wir eine
schöne runde Form bekommen und den
Braten wir einfach von beiden Seiten an
das ist alles währenddessen du da drüben
formst bereite ich Jesus Bernies vor
Estragon kommt rein es kommt Kerbel mit
rein auch Petersilie ist einfach
weggelassen weil wir haben schon so viel
Kräuter gekauft man sieht richtig hier
meine Lernkurve am Anfang das fällt noch
auseinander am Ende haben wir schon mal
so einen schönen runden und Reiskuchen
wenn man will für dieses einfach die
kräuterspiele die Kabel und es Stiele
einfach in den weiß reingeben einmal
aufkochen lassen ausziehen lassen
bisschen weißen Pfeffer mit rein ja und
wie große Kunst ist dann natürlich eine
schöne aber da sprechen wir von vielen
vielen Stunden eigentlich immer oder das
Einsetzen geht schnell in der Regel aber
danach wird es halt dann immer ein
bisschen zäher das warten lassen aber
das kann man ja machen wenn man Sonntag
spazieren geht oder mit der Frau
spazieren geht oder mit beiden ich hoffe
dass ich zumindestens ein paar präsent
habe
das war quasi mein Beitrag ich wollte
unbedingt diesen Cris drin haben ich
habe erfahren dass man den vorher auch
einfrieren kann quasi ausgestrichen auf
einem Backblech um ihn dann quasi
perfekt anzubraten so weißt du schon mal
gut aus für die Sauce Bernaise sind wir
jetzt ein bisschen Butter mit ein
bisschen die Butter lassen wir einfach
nur schmelzen und dann kommt nachher
eigentlich die hohe Kunst quasi das
Aufschlagen dafür trennen wir zwei Eier
im Eigelb sind immigatoren drin du
kennst das von der Mayonnaise nichts
anderes quasi ist noch Hollandaise ne
kurze Zeit später sieht euer Eis so aus
und dann würde ich einfach sagen Finish
sich das ganze mal oder ja wie lässt man
essen gut aus ich finde es ganz schlimm
wenn jetzt hier mir sowas passiert wo so
ein bisschen Gurke daneben fällt das das
regt mich wahnsinnig auf weil ich mir
einfach denke so dass das darf
eigentlich nicht sein also was man auf
jeden Fall sagen kann und muss den quasi
zu Chef von einem sternekopf das wird
den Moritz gar nicht gefallen
[Gelächter]
werden wahrscheinlich bei jedem Gericht
bei jedem Gang deutlich mehr als
benötigt von unserem Einkauf mit 40 €
haben abgesehen vom Rinderfilet reicht
das locker nachher für drei bis vier
Person guckt euch das bitte einfach mal
in seiner Pracht an und dann können wir
uns
[Musik]
sehen die nicht wunderschön aus und ganz
ehrlich das würde ich mit Kurs Hand
nehmen in dem gehobenen Restaurant
erstmal die Veggie Version
[Musik]
und es macht so Sinn aber wie knusprig
der Reis auch wirklich geworden ist
frische vom Koriander Cremigkeit von der
Avocado kommt ganz gefährlich das
schmeckt einfach fresh und zum Lack ich
habe schon probiert ich sag dazu jetzt
einfach mal nichts mehr dicke Portion
Lachs
der schmilzt im Mund das ist wirklich so
dass man sagt das muss irgendein Sushi
great ultra teurer lach sein aber
einfach dadurch die wir jetzt angemacht
haben wie du ihn angemacht hast ist der
so zart so weich es macht einfach jetzt
Sinn ja das macht absolut Sinn
Hauptgang also daran anzuknüpfen wird
nicht ganz leicht aber ich traue dir
einiges zu weiter geht's so magst ich
habe den Kuchen rausgeholt der ist
fertig der kühlt jetzt ein bisschen aus
ja ich glaube ich muss das auch noch
machen ganz schlecht
ganz gut aber wir probieren wir gleich
mal richtig ja deshalb nicht alles
verraten was machen wir als nächstes so
ich halte ein bisschen die Pflanze vor
und passiert gleich den such für die
Bernies ab wenn gleich unsere planscher
vorgeheizt kannst du das viele andere
raten okay jetzt gleich ein paar Tropfen
Öl rein richtig heiß anbraten es gibt ja
auch diesen Mythos Salzmann ein Fleisch
vor oder nach dem Garten davor dann
brennt das halt sich richtig schön rein
und macht mich halt absoluten Sinn wir
haben jetzt hier quasi gut aus unserer
Reduktion und jetzt fangen wir das halt
an auf zu schlagen du musst halt schauen
dass das Ei bin aber nicht drin das ist
ein Unterschied von 2 Grad 80 Grad
müssten wir haben das ist das ist fast
also an diejenigen die sich das nicht
zutrauen kauft einfach
jetzt sieht man hier sehr schön das so
richtig anfängt schaumig zu werden wie
das Ei bindet das wird immer schaumiger
und jetzt kommt der Punkt
du müsstest die Butter bitte einmal
reinlaufen lassen
Kräuter mit rein bisschen Pfeffer gerne
dieses Gruppenprojekt in der Schule wo
man einfach so seinen Namen drunter
schreibt so findet jetzt kommt immer die
große Frage wie kriegt man das perfekt
aufs Fleisch
manchmal ist es so einfach guck mal wie
sich das anschmiegt also dadurch dass
wir ja Paniermehl oder bzw mir die paar
beigegeben haben es wird oben knusprig
und in der Mitte sollte es schön fluffy
werden
jetzt können wir einfach mal Backofen
aufmachen ja und ist quasi auf unser
Ofengemüse drauflegen
und jetzt gehen wir auf komplette
Oberhitze die wir haben ja quasi
wirklich auf kreieren und in der
Zwischenzeit auch das circa so fünf
sechs Minuten im Ofen würde ich sagen
müssen wir jetzt ein bisschen warten so
und jetzt sieht man sehr schön wie die
Kruste hier langsam gratiniert wie die
butterblasen schmeckt wie oben anfängt
das zu karamellisieren das ist so direkt
aus wie so könnte ihr Essen genau
alles schön schöne Farben
geil und jetzt machen wir sogar noch
richtig tricky
wenn es jetzt noch schmecken würde was
sage ich immer was Gemüse nachher für
eine Farbe auf dem Teller darstellen
kann
super
also sorry aber auch wenn man das
einfach mal so fotografiert und jetzt
kommt der Clou da bin ich jetzt gespannt
wo du die
Platze Mamma Mia Alter also das
geisteskrank ja
also das spricht für sich da wir müssen
nicht über die Optik sagen das sieht
wunderschön aus und jetzt probiere ich
das ich bin die ganze Zeit schon
gespannt was macht diese Kruste von der
Soße oder zu wie der Koch sich gedacht
hat ne
[Musik]
ist ja so geil allein wegen der großen
bräuchten wir eigentlich keine Soße
Estragon ist das was so signifikant
aus Gemüse dazu ist genau was du sein
sollte eine Begleitung was in alle
Richtungen dich versorgt so und wenn man
jetzt mal ganz ehrlich ist man hat immer
irgendwas Gemüse im Haus haust du
einfach drauf das Filet ist halt auch
wirklich der Hauptcharakter du brauchst
es und das geiles durch diese Senfkörner
durch diese groben hast du einfach so
ein ganz kleinen
Vorspeise gebracht hat finde ich bringt
hier der Estragon und das ist so ein
roter Faden auch wenn man erstmal denkt
okay so crispy Rice und das aber geil
diese Panade die so viel Macht finde ich
auch hast du gemacht während ich drei
Möhren geschält habe so also es geht
schnell und das ist ein absolutes
Highlight müsst machen ich glaube alle
Geschmacksknospen sind befriedigt ja was
gibt da noch welche der süße Zahn der
süße Zahn möchte auch versorgt werden
ich kann nie warten ist alles fertig ist
ne ich warte auch nicht probiere auch
gut ne und jetzt haben wir quasi einen
Sorge zeigen was wirklich fix geht ohne
Eismaschine nimm einfach jetzt TK tief
vorne Himbeeren genommen also irgendwas
bäriges bietet sich immer an vielleicht
auch noch eine Mango Puderzucker ein
bisschen ganz bisschen was einfach ein
bisschen zu unterstützen die mir einfach
ein bisschen warmes Wasser dabei
währenddessen professionell Mix ein
bisschen unseren Kuchen für gar nicht
schlecht wenn das so ein bisschen
stückig ist auch ne also einige wenige
Stücke drin sind nicht ein bisschen
unsere zimtschmann-creme einfach so ein
bisschen Freestyle verteilen eigentlich
relativ smart
Alter darf ich es versuchen schon ganz
oft versucht zu sein das ist eine
bratanlocke
[Musik]
ein farbenfrost ist her schmeckt es so
gut wie es aussieht nehmen von einem
etwas sehr lecker Honignote kommt auch
krass durch und so oder crazy Leute
Endstufe wieder heute es geht deutlich
mehr mit 20 Euro pro Person als mit 10 €
pro Person ist es spannend sich
vorzustellen was noch möglich wäre wenn
es euch gefallen hat lass mal ein Like
da schaut bei Max vorbei ist natürlich
verlinkt danke dass du wieder einiges
gezeigt hast ne hier sein darf
[Musik]